the european parliament just approved
the resolution on the cop 26 that we
will take with us to glasgow our main
demand is to raise ambition to make sure
that we beat the 1.5
degree target that we have in the paris
agreement two years ago at the cope 25
in madrid we were left a bit empty
handed why
because the paris rule book wasn't
finished
but many things have changed in the last
two years we have the european green
deal we have the climate law and of
course now we have the fit for 55
package so the eu has translated all the
ambition into legislation to make sure
that we meet our
ambitions when it comes to climate
change we need to make sure we are
global net zero somewhere in the mid
century and be in reach of the 1.5
target second we need to protect
communities and natural habitat three we
need to mobilize enough financial
resources internationally to make sure
that our plans are feasible and four we
need to work together to make sure we
get the right results working together
between governments
industry and civil society and don't
forget the clock is ticking
you